good evening  can you believe that we are here  actually here  on our beautiful paradise high school  campus  to celebrate and welcome the paradise  high school  graduating class of 2019  back to the home field  the fact that we are here tonight  to celebrate this milestone is  americorps  [Music]  because you survived one of the most  destructive  wildfires in our nation's history  it left us a different people  you are the first generation of paradise  high school graduates  to rise from the ashes of what life was  and take a bold step forward into a new  and uncertain future but with what  you've been through  you have what it takes to persevere  and good luck